[Music]
[Applause]
he's bejan Robinson Falcons running back
he's got the commanders coming up at
1:00 how would you rate your rookie
season so
far um man I think it's been I think
it's been pretty fun man I think it's
been definitely a blessing um especially
like from what's going on but I think
it's headed towards the right track I'm
starting to get comfortable on the field
but it's it's it's definitely been a fun
a fun Journey up to this point are you a
running back being fast or a running
back being quick what's more
important um I think I think I can give
you like them in both categories like
yes it's going to be fast so when you
get past the second or the first level
you want to like have that Breakaway
speed but then if you're quick then you
got to you got to break tackles and you
know find leverage and like when you
your Quicks then Defenders are more
hesitant to come and Tackle you because
they don't know what you're going to do
so I think both are obviously important
but sometimes if you're super quick
running back then you can get your feet
in the ground quick enough to get past
the first level and second level so by
the way how' you feel about your
Longhorns against Oklahoma oh my gosh
man I was you know it was definitely a
tough one just cuz you know I know we we
made some some mistakes that if we
didn't make them we would have won the
game but
that last Drive I mean they they they
went down the field scored I was hurt it
was it was a bad it was a bad day for me
did you lose any Bets with teammates do
you have any uh teammates who went to
Oklahoma I did not um because I don't
think none of my teammates go to
Oklahoma but I did make a bet you know
one of the guys here uh you know David
he he he went to Oklahoma um years ago
so he gave me this real old Oklahoma
Jersey that I had to wear around the
facility yday it was it was bad man I
hated it uh what's been your welcome to
the NFL moment where somebody hit you
where and it's like whoa that's a little
different than uh College yeah I'll say
um probably probably my first game
against the Panthers the Panthers have a
linebacker uh louu and I was on a path
protection and he you know he just came
and bull rush me just as fast as he can
as hard as he can and like I picked it
up but I just felt all the power that he
was bringing in that one hit and I was
like all right I've never felt this one
before U but I'll say like that was
probably the welcome to the NFL moment
that I had are you watching the game
tonight do you care about the Chiefs and
Broncos yeah I mean I I watch I mean I'm
a football fan so I I'll watch the game
um you know see see what happens but you
know we we'll see we'll see I think I
think it's going to be a good game
tonight but but do you watch as a
football player or can you watch as a
fan I watch as a I watch as a fan okay
that's how that's how I watch it
obviously like as a football player
you'll critique some things yeah but I'm
just trying to watch it just for for the
fun of the game for me he's bejan
Robinson the Falcons running back the uh
eighth pick overall and uh got the
commanders on Sunday at one Eastern how
was
London London that that was a that was a
fun trip obviously like we want the win
uh but I think that you know me just
sightseeing and seeing all the historic
things that are in London like that was
a that was pretty special to be a part
of that and then especially like my
family was there so we got to do a lot
of different things um you know my
grandpa he just seen his face when he
when we were at the palace and like all
the all the different people and there's
a lot of fans in London which is which
is really cool like there's a lot of
football fans so you know I got to meet
a lot of different people um did you see
Prince William did you see the king did
you look for you know the royal family
we were trying so the flag the flag was
up the flag was up on the palace so that
you know when the flag's up that means
they're they're there yeah yeah so we
were trying to like get a sneak peek and
somebody was like yelling like everybody
watch out everybody watch out but it was
just like the the cleaning some cleaning
person that was trying to go so we we
were like all messed up man like we we
all thought we were G to see but it's
all good but it was It was a trip for
sure could you see playing full-time in
London I I can I can because I think I
think the fans really make the game you
know a lot of fun and you know I think
that it's a it's definitely something
that you know soccer's been the main
thing in in Europe but when you got a
football when you got a football fan
base that can that can take over as well
I think it could be definitely be a full
thing field Turf versus grass
yeah um personally I like I like grass
because it's I think it's just better
for your knees um but it feels like you
can trust your Cuts because of the turf
it's consistent whereas grass is so yeah
I mean it feels like both would benefit
you I lot see we play on Turf you know
with the Falcons um we practice on on
grass so I think that I think that's a
good thing just because like I get
different fields but a lot of a lot of
tur it's all different like you go to
different stadiums it could be a
different Turf it could be a different
grass so I think you just gotta get used
to it and that that's why you do pregame
um to make different cuts like in
pregame to see if you if you can make it
a longer cut or or you got to make it a
shortcut so I just kind of just see how
I feel before the game starts but I mean
if I would prefer grass you know as a
player but I mean mean if if it's Turf
like you just got to adapt and then go
with it I grew up uh in Cincinnati and I
I went to watch the
Bengals so so Paul
Robinson
was yes sir he was I think his nickname
was the cactus Comet and I think his
number was like 18 and didn't he go to
University of Arizona I and he was
rookie of the year so I got to see so is
he your great yes so that's un that's my
great my great uncle my great uncle
Uncle Paul I got to see him play that's
that's incredible you're the first
person to ever tell me that you got to
see him play yeah well nobody went to
see the Bengals play though bean I me
let's be honest but I just remember he
was the cactus Comet I think and he
Cactus Comet and and he had a he didn't
have a running back number I think it
was 18 Paulie is at 18 18 yeah yeah 18
yes I'm I'm I'mma call him and be like
you you the cactus comment
yes and he was he was great it just the
Bengals weren't but I just remember when
he came in it was like oh all right
Bengals got a running back here there we
go absolutely absolutely um hey great to
talk to you again and have fun against
the commanders are you worried about
anybody on the defensive side of the
ball with the
commanders um I mean I think they all
got you know great players uh their
dline is really good
you're wearing Commander Colors by the
way right now yeah so so this right here
it's my it's my South my uh High School
back home South Point Catholic it's my
high school okay but yes I think they
got I think they got you know really
good players are you the best football
player in the history of South
Point I mean a lot of people would say
that but well who's your competition
bejan there's been I mean there's been a
lot of great players there okay a lot of
great players okay okay I mean I know I
know I'm so you know super humble but uh
I think I can give some of them run for
their money say all right fair enough
fair enough are you in the Hall of Fame
at your high
school shoot I hope so what Paulie
Paulie is bejon in the Hall of Fame in
his high school I'm always on the
Southpoint website and I don't see his
name there for the South Point Sports
Hall of Fame well in my defense I just
that was like what three years ago when
I when I played there so I think they
like wait they got a way that's not a
5year waiting
period shouldn't they you rush for 7,000
yards in high school right yes sir 10
and something touchdowns yep they put
you in at halftime of one of those games
are like at as a sophomore they put you
in the Hall of Fame what are you what's
going on
there oh hey there a waiting get at this
point 7,000 yard what's the most yards
you ran for in a
game uh 400
and like 80 something yeah why didn't
you give your backup a chance why did
you have to why you got to H what you're
selfish that he he he was in he was in
at at Hassan that was like it was I know
it it was one of those games you you
could have just rush for a hundred and
then let the other guys have a chance
right yeah how many touchdowns you know
Paul Robinson would have let the other
guys run how many touchdowns did you
score in one game it was uh in one game
six okay see just imagine that guy you
went to school with he didn't get a
touchdown no he did well the guy behind
me was he was really good he went to he
went to Hawaii yeah but the guy behind
that guy behind that guy is walking
around now in Arizona going yeah I never
scored a touchdown in high school
because Bean scored six he was a ball
hog and not in the Hall of Fame now we
know why you're not in the Hall of
Fame now we know it's a shame you know
what yep we're going to keep an eye on
this story I gotta I got to figure this
out uh have fun against the commanders
once again great to talk to you as
always thank you bejan yeah thank you
yep bejan Robinson Falcons running back